e aí
e essa magia incrível que nós
conseguimos construir a tempo de poder
transformar essa ferramenta da
tecnologia como um espaço de conexão
antes dessa pandemia a tecnologia era um
obstáculo a nossa humanidade a gente se
distraiu com ela sem privilegiar o que
era mais importante na nossa vida e
agora o que é mais importante na nossa
vida só é possível acontecer se eu tenho
esse esse buraquinho verde aqui que eu
falo que é a chave de nárnia porque a
hora que eu entro aqui eu entro na casa
de milhares de pessoas e no coração
delas também esperam
e essa história né de pandemia nesse
tempo da humanidade trouxe para nós
possibilidade de escolher escolher de
que lado nós vamos ficar nessa história
o mundo está dividido em dois agora
mundo já era muito dividido mas agora de
fato não há tantas facções mas de
verdade estamos entre aqueles que ajudam
e aqueles que precisam de ajuda
e o espaço de quem atrapalha já foi
ocupado e não tem mais vaga não há mais
vagas disponíveis para as pessoas que
têm talento para trabalhar a gente é
percebendo com grande generosidade
especialmente no nosso país e quantidade
de pessoas ea quantidade de empenho que
elas têm em transformar-se a pandemia em
algo ainda mais aterrorizante
é mas que maravilha poder escolher de
que lado que eu posso ficar ficar do
lado de quem precisa de ajuda é algo que
permite uma consciência de algo que nos
falta algo que precisamos de saúde
física de saúde emocional de saúde
familiar de saúde social de saúde
profissional financeira e de saúde
espiritual e quando a gente percebe essa
escassez que a gente possa ser capaz de
escolher pedir ajuda
bom e quando a gente pede ajuda muito
importante que habite o nosso coração a
esperança a esperança de que nós teremos
ouvidos a esperança de que vão nos
ajudar a esperança de que nós não
estamos no lugar sem acesso a a isso
socorro e se a gente puder escolher esse
patch daqueles que ajudam a gente
precisa plantar dentro de nós a
capacidade de perdão porque nós vamos
ser capazes de ajudar o mundo inteiro
e eu e todas as pessoas que estão
trabalhando né como atividades
essenciais na área da assistência à
saúde a considerada uma área
assistencial área de transporte de
segurança na área de manutenção de
entrega de comida o supermercado da
produção de comida todas as áreas que
são consideradas essenciais a gente
infelizmente pode estar do lado de quem
ajuda mas essa capacidade de perdão
precisa acontecer porque nós vamos ser
capazes de ajudar a todas as pessoas que
precisam de ajuda
oi e aí a partir desse momento que nós
podemos nos perdoar a gente pode fazer
crescer dentro de nós uma capacidade
maior de se conectar da gente criar essa
conexão de amparo entre as pessoas que
precisam e aquelas que têm
oi e essa conexão pode permitir com que
cada um de nós no espaço de ajuda não
seja só a pessoa que entrega ajuda mas
que a gente possa ser a pessoa que
transforma numa ponte entre quem precisa
e quem pode ajudar essa capacidade de se
conectar muito disponível agora ao pé da
letra né a gente se conecta a gente pode
favorecer esse encontro para que a gente
não se torna uma pedra não só no sapato
mas que a gente não seja a pedra no
caminho de ninguém que nenhum de nós
possa ter que passar pelo terrível
momento de ser uma pedra um obstáculo na
vida na felicidade na amizade de
qualquer pessoa que merece essa ajuda e
que merece ser feliz apesar apesar de
tudo que a gente tá vivendo
e essa capacidade da gente se conectar
com pessoas que têm o mesmo propósito
que a gente que é o propósito de ajudar
nos esvazia da necessidade de sofrimento
pelas pessoas que atrapalham eu fui uma
das pessoas que no início dessa pandemia
acabei tendo colocando muita importância
nesse trabalho de despertar a
consciência das pessoas né sobre a
importância de você se responsabilizar
pelas pelas suas mãos né que nas tuas
mãos pode até a proteção e também pode
ser uma grande arma contra a humanidade
então o que a gente possa
é não desperdiçar energia com quem não
tem condição de compreender a
importância desse ato que no início
talvez até fizesse sentido mas agora é
importante que a gente pega essa energia
que eu nós temos agora que a gente
dedica as energia para quem pode ajudar
e para quem tá precisando de ajuda
e este momento daqui a pouco vai
terminar né nós vamos chegar vai chegar
um tempo onde nós vamos ter de volta a
possibilidade do encontro e nós
precisamos então também nesse momento de
recolhimento escolher quem nós vamos ser
quando a porta abrir
eu espero que a gente não se comporte
como barata que foge para dentro do
bueiro como muitos lugares nos vimos
fotos de pessoas que estavam correndo
para lojas para fazer em contas nós não
podemos mais nos comportar como insetos
como seres sem consciência sobre a
importância do que realmente tem valor
nessa vida
bom porque há muitos anos eu digo
convido né as pessoas já pensarem na
própria morte a pensar em que não somos
finitos que o nosso tempo vai acabar
há muitos anos eu vejo as pessoas quando
estão diante de uma doença que ameaça à
continuidade da vida delas que é o
momento de entrar ação do cuidado
paliativo essas pessoas se dando conta
do que realmente importa nessa vida e o
que realmente importa é a nossa
capacidade de sermos eternos no coração
de quem a gente ama então nesse momento
onde todos nós toda a humanidade recebeu
a notícia de que pode acontecer com
qualquer um de nós não precisa ser velho
não precisa ser pessoa de grupo de risco
tá acontecendo com todo mundo
oi e essa consciência de que pode
acontecer conosco também nos dá a
oportunidade de mais uma escolha
e se você pudesse já começar a estudar
as suas últimas palavras para que você
habite o coração das pessoas que você
ama sendo lembrado por estas últimas
palavras quais seriam qual seria a sua
última cena seria um chilique dizendo
que tá entediado ou você diria eu amo
tanto você que eu gostaria que você
salvasse minha vida nós podemos fazer
essas escolhas porque quem tá
provavelmente assistindo aqui faz parte
do grupo que pode escolher ajudar então
dentro de você mesmo existe também dois
espaços um espaço de quem ajuda e um
espaço de quem precisa de ajuda e a
primeira vida que você tem que salvar é
a sua muito obrigada
e eu filhota stephanie obrigada te deu
um gatinho rosa sensacional muito bom é
isso aí eu saber o que que nós vamos
falar daqui para frente faz alguns
costumes e